in this video we're going to look at how
to communicate more clearly this one's
really important so let's get into it
[Music]
I'd like to start with a paraphrase from
Aristotle clear speaking demonstrates
clear thinking and that's the topic of
this video
clear communication mainly through a
three-part framework that I will be
showing you and the main idea of this
whole video is that this is the way
leaders communicate they almost all
communicate in this three-part framework
and I'd like to give you three tips to
help you move in that direction now the
first tip sounds easy but it takes a
little work to get there and that is to
figure out what your main idea is if
you're writing a college essay this is
called your thesis statement and as you
probably know it takes a little bit of
work and reflection and a lot of
crossing out rewriting things to figure
out how to say your main point in about
one crisp sentence that takes some work
but the extra effort it takes to get
there will help you communicate much
more clearly so in any kind of meeting
situation conversation presentation
email voicemail you have to figure out
what your bottom line is tip number two
once you have figured out what your
bottom line is you want to break that
bottom line down into three main points
or three buckets you want to figure out
what you want to say first second and
third and once you figure that out you
have a basic structure that you can
communicate and offer now if you're in a
longer presentation or a meeting you
have to preview these ideas and then
give some detail if it's a short
conversation or an email you can just
share them by listing them one at a time
so let's just assume for a second you've
given your main point and then you've
previewed your three main points across
you've given a little roadmap for a
second third the next thing you want to
do is circle back around to the first
one and signpost remind people that
you're talking about your first point
once you give all the details for that
first point you go to your second point
and you say secondly and then you should
your second point details and once
you're done with that you say third and
then you give your details under your
third main point if you only give your
thesis in your preview statement and you
don't then remind people by signposting
each of the main points it's easy to get
lost in all the details of those main
points so it's very important if you
want to communicate clearly to give
those reminders there are called
signpost little points along the way
where you remind people just in case
they got distracted now I'm talking
about my second point and finally my
third point now I often get the question
why three main points what if I have ten
things that I need to share well if
you're still stuck with a whole bunch of
items like eight nine or ten items
chances are you haven't taken the time
to step back a level and think about how
you might sort these into three main
points we're going to remember three
we're not going to remember ten so
usually if you look at a list of 10 or
so items you can create slightly larger
categories that you can bucket those
ideas into until you come up with around
three main points now in any given day
if you have two main points or four main
points that probably doesn't matter you
always want to shoot for three though
and that's a good discipline and have it
to establish so let's give some concrete
examples couple years ago I lost about
50 pounds and naturally many people have
asked me how did you lose 50 pounds and
this is how I would answer my headline
was I had a three-part plan for losing
the weight first I counted calories next
I exercise more and third I stayed
motivated with a friend now if this were
a normal conversation I would just say
it like that but if we were having some
kind of meeting update let's say then I
would circle back around give my first
main point again the details signposts
the second main point then give the
details signpost the third main point
and then give the details but this was
just a normal conversation so I don't go
into that let's give another example
let's say you're going to do an update
and you're meeting and the question is
how are things going in your meeting
your headline would be growth it's great
but it's causing strain first employees
are getting burned out second it's been
hard to hire new people and third
quality is starting to slip and again if
this were a meeting with more details I
would then add those details and give
the sign post now let's say you're
visiting a physician and you have
something wrong with your eyes and you
would say doctor what's
wrong with my eyes and half after he or
she examined you the doctor might say
something like this you have pinkeye
that's the headline the causes or it's a
virus and it gets in there from touching
your eyes symptoms or it's red and get
itchy eyes as you can see and the
treatment are these eye drops that I
would like to prescribe to you so that's
how this sounds when you give a nice
headline and three main points it sounds
extremely clear and the whole thing is
built for your listeners so that it'll
stick now the third point I want to
share with you is a tip about using this
three-part framework not just for
communicating but for thinking and
analyzing and listening and here's what
I mean this is a tool not just for
expressing yourself but for processing
the communication that you're exposed to
so let's say you're listening and you're
at the flow you're in the flow of a
meeting with some people at work or
among some friends I recommend that you
start taking notes and trying to figure
out what people's headlines are and what
their buckets are this is an extremely
valuable analytical skill that will help
you distill the messages that you're
hearing around you you'll become an
a-plus listener for content almost
overnight when you start doing this so
this is not just a way to express
yourself like a leader and express
yourself clearly it's a tool that you
can use to analyze and think more
clearly and if you're doing it when
you're communicating and also when
you're processing information you'll
really up your game and your skills in
this area so in sum this three-part
framework will help you communicate much
more clearly you'll communicate like a
leader and you'll start to think like a
leader as well in terms of your homework
your action that like you take the very
next conversation meeting email
voicemail presentation anything where
you know you're going to communicate I
would like you to shape it into this
headline and three main points and watch
this become a habit over time and I'd
like to finish with a quotation by Paul
Meyer
he says communication is the key to
personal and career success so thanks
and I will see you in the next video
hope you found that video on clear
communicate
helpful if you don't know this yet
you're in the middle of a series on
essential professional communication
skills the first lesson was on concise
communication the one you just watch is
on clear communication and coming up
next we have listening skills positive
relationships and collaborative
problem-solving I'll put links all in a
row to those videos in the description
below this video and I'll try to link to
it in the card above here as well and at
any point if you would like to download
the free quick guide to this mini course
you can do that as well it's a PDF with
all the tips summarized and links to all
the individual videos so I encourage you
to check that out I will also put a link
to that in the description below the
video as well as in this card that
should be popping out right about here
so let's get into the next lesson on
listening skills